a diplomatic wrist slap China's man in
Britain summoned to the Foreign Office
in a row over Hong Kong it came after
this diplomatic punch and off Hongkong
and you know show respect of the what
has been achieved the Ambassador used a
rare press conference to express Chinese
anger at British support for
pro-democracy protesters in Hong Kong on
this very important issue of a principle
the UK government chose to stand on the
run site it has made inappropriate
remarks not only to interfere in the
internal affairs of Hong Kong but also
to back up a violent lawbreakers we
strongly condemn and oppose the cross
interference in Hong Kong affairs and
China's internal affairs by the British
society the world's second largest
economy warned Britain it's meddling
came at a price
I think the relationship in a way has
been damaged by the interference of a
British government Hong Kong because as
I said the fundamental principles
guiding our two countries is a mutual
respect non-interference into internal
affairs
if British government go further it will
cause further damages this is the damage
that deepened London's rift with Beijing
over its former colony on Monday Hong
Kong's parliament was breached for the
first time ever a flash of violence
after weeks of peaceful protest against
greater Chinese control here the
shattered after ma many watched in
horror as protesters broke in among them
Gordon Wong a police officer for more
than 30 years we don't like them those
people those violent protesters they are
affected by other people those young
people were reared were fat with wrong
information
Britain hasn't condoned the use of force
but it supports people's right to
peaceful protest to protect the freedoms
they enjoy this is what the foreign
secretary told skies Kay Burley on
Monday we signed an agreement with China
in 1984 was actually Margaret Thatcher
and Deng Xiaoping who signed the joint
declaration which guarantee what's
called the the one country two systems'
promise for 50 years for Hong Kong and
that has been the foundation of Hong
Kong success
Beijing says London no longer has a
right to an opinion on this city Britain
disagrees this puts the two countries on
a collision course it can only worsen
the longer the turbulence in Hong Kong
continues Deborah Haynes Sky News
[Music]